on Tuesday affinity magazine a social
justice teen magazine tweeted out this
insanity as the world's reacted to the
death of college student otto ampere
murdered by the North Koreans for the
sin of removing a poster from a wall to
bring home quote watch whiteness work he
wasn't the kid or innocent can't go to
another country and try to steal from
them respect their laws
unfortunately the tots make cakes so hot
it would actually consume the Sun with
tone he wasn't the only left-wing
attempt to slam alarm here for the
brutal sin of whiteness The Huffington
Post ran a piece after WOM beer was
sentenced a few months ago to over a
decade in jail in North Korea in which
the author stated quote my mother's
callous reaction to Michael faiths
sentence is my reaction to another young
white man who went to an Asian country
and violated their laws and learned that
his the shield his sis wife male
identity provides here in America is not
Teflon abroad I'm a black woman though
the hopeless fear warmbier is now
experiencing is my daily reality living
in a country or white men like him are
willfully oblivious to my suffering even
as they are complicit in maintaining the
power structures which ensured their
supremacy at my expense
he is known outsider at the mercy of a
government unfazed by his cries for help
I get it very well more that
ripped warm beer as a frat boy and quote
frat boy privilege not valid in
totalitarian dystopias funny
well more never had anything to say
about his rich and famous friends
visiting the gulag state of Cuba this
sort of stupidity from the West isn't
uncommon it merely demonstrates that
when you see the world in terms of class
color or sexual orientation when you are
convinced that every white straight male
is a victimizer you are more likely to
excuse atrocities against such fortunate
people never mind
North Korea is filled with North Koreans
tortured and prison murder kept enslaved
light conditions
warm beer clearly had it coming because
he was white extended to the politics of
the United States this sort of moral
garbage leads to the breakdown of
society if you believe that every
terrible thing that happens to a member
of an Alf group is justified you are a
tribalist
leftist politicians have spent decades
pandering to such tribalism and in
response there's been an upsurge of
tribalism from the anti labs the victims
like otto warmbier remain victims but if
we fail to see them as victims because
we're too concerned with the color of
their skin we become their victimizers -
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
all right so you know there's a lot of
news breaking out of North Korea we're
going to talk about that in the history
of how we got to where we are in North
Korea and what it tells us about foreign
policy we're also going to talk about
the breakdown in the health care bill
how that is working out lot to get to
various and sundry items but before we
do any of that first I want to say
thanks to our supporters over at zip
recruiter they are our sponsors of
course and if you are concerned about
the level of the employees that you have
been hiring as we so clearly are here at
the Daily wire which is why we just
fired half of them then what we are
going to do is we are going to provide
you with a way to recruit the very best
and that is zip recruiter comm slash
Daily wire you can post your job to a
hundred-plus job sites with just one
quick and then their powerful technology
matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else
zip recruiter is different because it
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them 80 percent of job posting
on zip recruiter to get a qualified
candidate in 24 hours or less no
juggling emails or calls to your office
simply screen rate manage candidates all
in one place with zip recruiters easy to
use dashboard you can find out today why
zip recruiter is being used by
businesses of all sizes including over
here at the Daily wire go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire and you
can now post jobs on zip recruiter for
free that is right you post them for
free at zip recruiters comm slash Daily
wire zip recruit comm slash daily wire
make sure you use that slash daily wire
so that you get the free deal and also
so that they can ensure that we sent you
and continue advertising with us okay so
for those who missed the news yesterday
I mean it's just an awful awful awful
story out of Lauren because 22 year olds
University of Virginia student he was
apprehended by the North Korean
government in prison for 17 months why
what did he do supposedly he attempted
to steal a propaganda sign praising
North Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon from
a hotel and then last week he was
released you recall but he was released
in a coma and then he died at a
Cincinnati hospital surrounded by his
family they released a statement the
family did they said it is our sad duty
to report that our son otto warmbier has
completed his journey home surrounded by
his loving family otto died today at
2:20 p.m. it would be easy at a moment
like this to focus on all that we lost
future time that won't be spelled warm
and
a brilliant young man whose curiosity
and enthusiasm for life knew no bounds
but we choose to focus on the time we
were given to be with this remarkable
person you can tell from the outpouring
of emotion from the communities to be
touched Wyoming Ohio University of
Virginia just named to that the love for
otto went well beyond his immediate
family when Otto returns Cincinnati late
on June 13th he was unable to speak
unable to see unable to react to verbal
comments he looked very uncomfortable
almost anguished although we would never
hear his voice again within a day the
countess's states changed he was at
peace he was home we believe he could
sense that we think everyone around the
world who has kept him in our family in
our thoughts and prayers we are at peace
and at home too just horrifying
horrifying story basically there is no
question that the North Korean
government essentially beat the living
crap out of him they said that botulism
and a sleeping pill had led to the coma
which is just not us doctor said that's
just a lie a spokesman for the State
Department said the sentence meted out
to warmbier was a response to US
sanctions against North Korea for its
nuclear activities warrior's father said
his son was forced to confess and whose
detained for political purposes News
active in Spanish a fraternity and the
hillo campus organizations Jewish campus
organization whose salutatorian at his
high school who was detained at
Pyongyang Airport the North Koreans
claimed that he entered the country
under the guise of a Torsen plotted to
destroy North Korean unity with the
quote tacit connivance of the US
government and under its manipulation
apparently he said that he was he
confessed to stealing a piece of North
Korean propaganda his confession said
that he stole the banner for the mother
of a friend who wanted as a souvenir to
hang on the church at home he said he
was offered to used cover the $10,000
payment if he was detained and didn't
return $200,000 would be paid to his
mother in the form of a charitable
donation he said that he took the chance
because his family was suffering from
very severe financial difficulties he
also said he was urged to steal the
poster by a semi secret ring Society his
confession said I never never should
have allowed myself to be lured by the
United States administration's commit a
crime in this country no question he was
coerced into doing all of this he said I
entirely beg you the people in the
government of the DPRK for your
forgiveness please I made the worst
mistake of my life and apparently
according to his parents they said that
the Obama administration urged them to
keep quiet Fred said they feel you don't
get involved that way let the other side
solve problems and make
things happen is that there's no excuse
for the way North Koreans treated our
son well obviously it is an act of war
technically for a foreign government to
detain torture and murder an American
citizen this is horrific beyond all
measure it truly is heroes president's
response the president Trump's response
to the news that out of warm beer died
yesterday here's what he had to say we
were so happy to see him even though he
was in very tough condition but he just
passed away with alone it's a brutal
regime you'll be--you'll and okay well
you know it is a weak statement but
honest-to-goodness I don't know what
people expect from Trump at this point
there are some measures that Trump could
pursue against North Korea mainly he
needs to pursue sanctions against the
Chinese government that sponsors North
Korea and that means cracking down on
Chinese banks that sponsor North Korea
one of the problems here is of course
that with some 13,000 artillery pieces
pointed at Seoul not all of which can
hit the city in South Korea but many of
which can the notion of a first strike
on North Korea carries significant risk
the Chinese government's not going to do
much to hamper kim jeong-hoon but
obviously aside from sanctions we have
to increase propaganda into North Korea
we have to push to throw North Korea out
of the United Nations for whatever
that's worth and we ought to consider as
I say taking financial measures against
the Chinese government which has been
sponsoring and keeping Kim Jong Un's
evil regime in power for the last 50 odd
years Eric Bolling considered the
possibility on Fox News that maybe we
should preemptively strike North Korea
over this this is being directly
affected by this North Korean crazy
dictator it may be time for a preemptive
strike now is that realistic to do a
preemptive strike on North Korea I don't
know all the military details you'd have
to ask general mattis about it I'm sure
that we have considered the possibility
I do want to trace however I think it's
important because this has ramifications
for general American foreign policy I do
want to trace for a second you know
leave aside the less evil reaction to
otto warmbier
original conviction for a moment which
is just totally evil I want to point out
that when it comes to American foreign
policy American foreign policy is sort
of like
comedy of errors we've ever seen a
comedy very Shakespearean comedy there's
usually it starts with somebody telling
a fib and then that fib turns into three
more fibs and then those three more fibs
turn into 8/5 if you've ever seen a
tragedy it's the same thing so makes a
bad decision that bad decision sort of
radiates outward like a ripple in a pond
and effect they've been ever broadening
number of people that's sort of American
foreign policy as well the reason that
otto warmbier is dead today is not just
because of Kim jong-un it's because
Western foreign policy for nearly a
century there are a series of points in
American foreign policy where all of
this could have been stopped before it
began with North Korea and at virtually
every turn the wrong mistakes were made
with regard to Western foreign policy
and this is why I'm not an isolationist
I think isolationism is an easy way to
avoid making tough decisions in the now
they have tremendous ramifications down
the road so to take the example of North
Korea back in 1917 all the way back to
1917 there's the Russian Revolution in
the middle of the Russian Revolution
which was happening in the middle of
World War one there was an attempt by
the Communists to take over the country
first Tsar Nicholas felt and then after
the tower fell then there was a battle
between the so-called whites and the
Reds the whites were socialists and the
Reds were communists the whites were led
by a guy named Kerensky and the Reds
were of course led by Lenin and the
Western world basically said we want to
help the whites witness war so the
British and Americans actually put
troops on the ground in 1917 1918 in
Russia it was called the polar bear
expedition for the Americans and the
goal is to help the whites beat back the
Reds now if that had succeeded there is
no Soviet Union the Soviet Union doesn't
exist the the murder of the mass murder
of tens of millions of people over the
course of the 20th century doesn't
happen but Woodrow Wilson ended up
withdrawing because he didn't have
public support for what really was a
tiny operation the same thing happened
with Britain in 1919 the British pulled
out against the advice of Winston
Churchill the British prime minister
named Lloyd George he said the country
could quote not afford to continue so
costly an intervention an interminable
Civil War what was that costly
intervention the British to that point
had lost 327 men for the next 70 years
hundreds of millions of people would die
thanks to the rise of the Soviet Union
three decades later the United States
made a very similar decision in
18:45 China was at war shanghai shocked
the nationalist leader was at war with
Mountain Kong the Communists and the
Truman administration tried to bring all
parties to the table saying they didn't
want to take sides in the Civil War they
actively stopped Chiang kai-shek from
wiping mal off the map in 1946 George
Marshall who was at the time the top
American general he helped stop an
offensive by the Nationalists that would
have crushed mal Marshall actually
berated Chiang kai-shek he said under
the circumstances of the continued
advance of the government troops in
Manchuria I must repeat that a point is
being reached or the integrity of my
position is open to serious question
therefore I request you again to
immediately issue an order terminating
advances attacks or pursuits by
government troops mao biographers jung
chang right marshals dicta was probably
the single most important decision
affecting the outcome of the Civil War
Shanghai shek backed off because he was
afraid that he would lose the money in
American support and that now when the
war as it turned out that failure the
ceasefire that they engaged in allowed
now to regroup and in mountains of
taking over the country how does this
have ramifications from North Korea well
without mal there is no North Korea
remember that the Korean War begins when
the Chinese government decides that they
are going to intervene and help out the
the via helped out the the North Korean
the North Korean communists and they
cross into South Korea as well over that
38th parallel the United States
guarantees the safety of the South
Koreans we cross back over the 38th
parallel and we drive them all the way
back up to the Yellow River at which
point the Chinese port 200,000 men over
the border General Douglas MacArthur at
that point said okay let's bomb the
Chinese bases
let's topple the Chinese government
let's have the Nationalists come in and
knock out let's bring time I check back
and let's knock out the Chinese
Communists and from Taiwan and and
Truman says no we can't do that so South
Korea is preserved as an independent as
an independent republic but north korea
falls to the Communists in essentially
late 1950 now does that mean that Truman
made the right decision it's sort of
unclear this is one of those historical
what if that we're never going to know
the answer to obvious who had been even
more costly war if we had not withdrawn
below the 38th parallel however it is
important to note that it each step
along this chain smaller sacrifices
because we avoided them end up mandating
larger interventions right if we did
intervene
Soviet Union in 1917 before it's the
Soviet Union maybe it costs a certain
amount money and a relatively small
number of troops each one of which is a
tragedy but when we're talking about
foreign policy you do have to talk about
numbers we don't do that until we end up
with a Cold War and world war 2 which
probably never would have happened if
there is no Soviet Union very difficult
to imagine that the Nazis even rise to
power in the absence of the Soviet Union
because the Nazis were a direct response
actually to the rise of the Soviet Union
and the rise of the Communists in Nazi
Germany and pre Nazi Germany in Weimar
Germany
if so again small sacrifices made then
prevents the rise of the Soviet Union
small sacrifice made in 1945 financially
to Shanghai shek and not tying his hands
prevents the rise of the Chinese
Communists and then you end up in the
Korean War and now we have basically an
intractable problem the North Koreans
are not going to go away anytime soon
the reason I say this is because I think
it has ramifications for how we deal
with foreign policy today there's a
tendency on right and left to say that
isolationism is the best possible
solution to these problems we just stay
out of the world civil wars we just stay
out of the world's problems then things
will get better this is sort of the
Obama administration cap with regard to
Iraq which we would throw everything
will be fine and then naturally you get
Isis the same sort of thing happens all
around the world on a regular basis that
doesn't mean every intervention is
necessary and we have to carefully
consider and sometimes an intervention
is going to fail sometimes an
intervention is going to be
counterproductive but that doesn't
absolve us of the obligation to look the
future straight in the eye and determine
whether we believe that this problem is
going to balloon into a far larger
problem over time so again I don't have
any good solutions from North Korea
that's why I am NOT ripping on President
Trump for having no good solutions from
North Korea there are no good solutions
for North Korea at this point short of
pressuring the Chinese government which
so far we have not had the the
willingness to do you know President
Trump was actually more right on North
Korea before he met with the Chinese
than he was after he met with Chinese
government it is tragic it is horrifying
and please for the love of God people do
not go to evil dictatorships for any
reason because you never know what is
going to happen there it's just
horrifying okay well before we go any
further and I do want to talk about the
the Democratic in can
that is currently breaking out over
president Trump it's continuing rather
over president Trump also on talk about
amazon.com because there's now a call
from the left to break up Amazon which
is just nuts but before I do that I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
math Weldon so if you want the best
underwear that are possible to have in
the entire universe math Weldon comm is
the place to go these underwear are
comfortable they are antimicrobial
they're they're undergarments are
antimicrobial they've antimicrobial
shirts which means they eliminate odor
there's not just comfortable they are
durable
I have several pairs of math wells in
underwear and unlike other brands of
underwear that fall apart after several
wears math welds and books basically the
same today as it did when it came out of
the package just fantastic stuff socks
shirts undershirts woody sweat pants
super comfortable something you can wear
in stuff you can wear out when I go home
I don't dress like million bucks that I
do here but I look as good as I possibly
can and I feel as good as I possibly can
in my math Weldon gear because they are
the best so right now if you go to math
Weldon calm and use promo code Shapiro's
promo code Shapiro's you get 20% off
your order at Maxwell's and.com that
spelled ma CK wel gon calm Mac Weldon
calm and get 20% off using that promo
code Shapiro again yeah the fact is that
their their underwear are higher quality
than anything that you're going to get
at one of the department stores really
terrific stuff I wear them every day not
the same paradise I change up the pairs
okay so I think the Al Franken sort of
gave away the game yesterday when he was
talking about why it is that he opposes
President Trump so Al Franken came out
and said that he is it it's actually
pretty spectacular he came out and he
said that the big problem here is pence
you know this I think demonstrates that
when it comes to the left attempt to get
president Trump it has very little to do
with their actual worries about
president Trump they don't actually
think the president Trump is the biggest
problem if I were a Democrat at this
point I would be a lot more afraid of
pence than Trump just for political
reasons pence seems more competent he
has more principles he knows how to work
with Congress
Trump has problems on all of these
scores but here's what Franken said he
said quote he's ideological I can
him to be a zealot does not pen I think
that in terms of domestic policy
certainly would be worse than Trump so
he's saying we should be careful about
getting rid of Trump because then you
might end up with pence which just
demonstrates this is all political hacks
job anyway all the Russian collusion
stuff it has nothing to do with actual
Russian collusion it has to do a lot
more with the fact that they are trying
to hamstring Trump's agenda and again
talking about Pence's efficacy I think
it's important to go back to 2016 when
the Democrats were all saying that Rubio
would be scarier than Trump to them in
office Trump sir should take note this
demonstrates two things one you are
absolutely correct that the left is the
out to get Trump for unjustified reasons
this is not about his corruption this is
not about anything terrible that he's
done but number two you should take note
that Democrats truly are more afraid of
Republicans who are good at this and
they are Trump which would suggest that
Trump needs to get better at this which
brings us to the health care at
negotiation so right now Republicans are
negotiating behind closed doors this
health care bill and we're not carrying
out a lot from the Senate because Mitch
McConnell Run that runs that place as a
tight ship I don't have a problem with
em negotiating about it behind closed
doors I do have a problem with them
releasing the bill and then within five
seconds voting on the bill but something
the Democrats did as well it's not good
when the Obama people did it it's not
good when the Trump people do it here's
Bernie Sanders saying Republicans are
cowardly for refusing to release any
sort of text we are not a poor country
we should not be talking about severe
austerity efforts we are the richest
country in the history of the world most
people don't know that because almost
all new income and wealth is going to
the people on top but you do know that
Elizabeth knows that and I know it and
our job is ask the simple question okay
does Obamacare have problems absolutely
deductibles too high too many people
remain uninsured prescription drug costs
too high etc how do we deal with it
that's the rationale discussions right
the answer is not to make a difficult
situation much much worse and again
getting back to the initial point our
Republican colleagues are so cowardly
are so frightful that the American
people will learn what's in their
legislation they refuse to have one
hearing one open discussion and there is
fused about the lack of pudding cups in
this room well I think that's right I
think that's right senator Sanders I
love that Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren in the same place at the same
time the universe should actually
implode on itself out of the socialistic
stupidity in that room Elizabeth Warren
is not a dumb lady but she certainly
talked them when it comes to economics
and pandering to our left to space but
Bernie Sanders is wrong about a lot of
things here when he says that were the
richest country in the history of the
world we can afford health care for
everyone no ok we are the richest
country in the history of the world we
also have the most debt of any country
in the history of the world and that is
not going to go away if you start paying
for everybody's health care and then
you're going to have to ration
everybody's health care because you
can't have unlimited cost and then
limited coverage that's not the way that
works but he's right about the fact that
Republicans are ramming this thing
through I have one thing to say about
this if somebody is keeping a secret
from you unless it's a Valentine's Day
gift from your significant other it's
going to be bad ok there's never been a
secret kept from you that ends up being
a great secret when it comes out so the
fact that Republicans are doing all this
behind closed doors should not be
encouraging to a lot of Republicans who
actually want to see Obamacare repealed
apparently they're going to dump a lot
of money into it Obamacare style that's
not good for the Republicans oh and talk
a little more about that plus leftist
attempt to shut down amazon.com in just
a second but for that you have to go
over to Daley wired.com right now and
subscribe plus we're going to
deconstruct the culture today lots of
deconstructing of the culture we talked
Beatles and Katy Perry all sorts of fun
things today and deconstructing the
culture you want to check that out if $8
a month gets you your subscription and
if you want an annual subscription then
you get a free signed copy of this very
book say it's so booked by me and my
pops about you should hog the white
socks 2005 the championship season it's
really more about baseball and fathers
and sons you don't have to be a Sox fan
in order to enjoy the book obviously if
I thought that you did have to be a Sox
guy we wouldn't have written it because
there are three of us my dad and me and
sort of well two and a half President
Obama says he has been any case can get
a signed copy of saying so when you
become an annual subscriber plus you get
to be part of the mailbag which we now
do on Fridays you get to be part of
Andrew clavin's mailbag we have some
brand-new shows that are coming that
you're going to be able to be a part of
if you become an annual subscriber or
subscriber go over to Daley we're calm
right now and subscribe or check this
out later over at iTunes or SoundCloud
make sure that you subscribe download
the show and make sure that you also
leave us a
a review we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you